in this video we will learn something
called a symmetric matrix yes a
symmetric matrix when can we say that a
matrix is symmetric matrix a is
symmetric if a transpose is equal to a
understand this well the transpose of
the matrix is equal to the matrix itself
this is the definition of a symmetric
matrix look at this matrix a is it
symmetric what does the definition say
it will be symmetric only if its
transpose is equal to itself so what is
a transpose here
we interchange the rows and columns we
get a transpose as 1 2 the first row
became the first column and the second
row became the second column are they
equal when are two matrices equal do you
remember equality of matrices two
matrices are equal if they're of the
same order and if the corresponding
elements are equal here the orders are
different the order of a is two by one
and that of a transpose is 1 by 2 they
are not equal because a transpose is not
equal to a we say that a is not a
symmetric matrix that's how easy it is
to find out if a matrix is symmetric or
not we find its transpose and check if
it's equal to the original matrix if not
then the matrix is not symmetric let's
take another example here's matrix B is
matrix be symmetric pause the video and
find out if B is a symmetric matrix to
know if B is symmetric we find B
transpose first the first row becomes
the first column 1 for the second row
becomes the second column minus 1 2 and
the third row becomes the third column 0
3 this is B transpose R B and B
transpose equal the order of B
is three by two and that of B transpose
is 2x3 as the orders are different they
are not equal which means B is not a
symmetric matrix this should give us a
hint tell me can a rectangular matrix
ever be symmetric a rectangular matrix
is a matrix in which the number of rows
is not equal to the number of columns
can it ever be symmetric no chance
because the order of the transpose will
definitely be different from that of the
matrix only a square matrix can be
symmetric a square matrix is a matrix in
which the number of rows is equal to the
number of columns take matrix C for
instance two rows and two columns this
is a square matrix because it's number
of rows is equal to its number of
columns is this a symmetric matrix we
find C transpose to know the answer the
first row becomes the first column one
two and the second row becomes the
second column to four clearly the two
matrices are equal same order and the
corresponding elements are equal 1 + 1 2
1 2 2 + 2 4 and for matrix C is a
symmetric matrix as its transpose is
equal to itself does this mean that
every square matrix will be symmetric
here's matrix D it's a square matrix
because it's number of rows is equal to
its number of columns pause the video
and find out if matrix D is a symmetric
matrix to know if D is symmetric we need
to find D transpose first the first row
will be the first column here 1 3 1 the
second row becomes the second column - 1
1 4 and the third row will be the third
column here 2 1 0 add these two matrices
equal the orders are equal yes but
the corresponding elements equal let's
check one is equal to 1 3 is not equal
to minus 1 for 2 matrices to be equal
all the corresponding elements must be
equal as 3 is not equal to minus 1 these
two matrices are not equal D is not a
symmetric matrix and it is not equal to
its transpose so remember every square
matrix need not be symmetric but for a
matrix to be symmetric it has to be a
square like in the first two examples
the matrices were not square so they
will surely be non symmetric but if they
are square then they may or may not be
symmetric here's one last example you
need to solve this is matrix e pause the
video and find out if it's symmetric the
first thing we need to check is if the
matrix is a square matrix as it has
equal number of rows and columns we can
say that it is a square matrix so it may
or may not be symmetric to find out if
it's symmetric we need to find e
transpose this is what we get by
interchanging the rows and columns of e
first row first column second row second
column and third row third column both
matrices have the same orders and the
corresponding elements are also equal
matrix E is equal to e transpose matrix
E is symmetric with this we can modify
the original definition a bit we say
that a square matrix a is symmetric if a
transpose is equal to a this is a better
way to understand it if it's not square
we can directly say that it's not
symmetric and if it is square we find a
transpose and check if it's equal to
matrix a if it's equal we say that the
matrix is symmetric